il ya le serbe bon soir entre a fait une
entrée remarquée en littérature en 1974
avec l'anti voyage alors après il ya le
diable vert le roi et les voleurs et
april 10 livres en 14
quand même
j'ai fait le compte
oui c'est ça et on a parlé de thèmes est
assise la servir
en parlant de muriel serpent par les
deux thèmes servir à je vais pas te
demander ce que c'est je vais te dire il
ya l'astrologie
il ya les chats parce que tu vivais avec
ta grand mère fait partie de la légende
vivait avec ta grand mère et ton chat
c'est vrai il ya l'exotisme et le
narcissisme très présent dans tes livres
tu disais en parlant de pas de toi mais
enfin parlant de l'héroïne dans un de
ses livres
c'était bébé en ct brigitte bardot en
plus petits elle avait les seins de
marilyn et les yeux violets d'elizabeth
taylor salaire si vous se passe on
accusa c'est un peu facile qui vient
comme ça c'est pas grave demeure surtout
quand on se mettrait sur la table alors
il est très facile quand les femmes qui
le fait de dire alors c'est du
narcissisme je veux dire que la pluie
ait cessé complètement adhérents
l'humour ça parce que nous faisons là
par exemple c'est non mais tu étais
jeune femme parce que possible des
objectifs à tenir bon c'était comme tout
personnage pour un auteur
c'est un marionnettes dans lesquels on
met les mains on met les bois et j'avais
besoin parce que cette fille allait
vivre des choses à terrible de lui
donner
cette réponse à tous qui est la beauté
absolue mais alors il ya la ponctuation
ça c'est très très remarquée par là par
la critique ses célèbres une pâle botté
par exemple ça commence par une phrase
qui dure 180 3
bah oui c'est une question respiration
j'ai souvent au contenu quand je parle
j'ai déjà parlé la situation fréquent
puisque j'ai souvent à la bouche des
sages mais quand j'écris ses confrères
quand tu parles d'un vent tu dis là
tanner recelant de somptueux et puis de
magistère sequana ténor et bien c'est
l'instrument dans les casses et
l'alambic qu'elles lâchent les
alchimistes faisait à partir de deux
éléments différents le troisième élément
inconnu
et quand tu dis par exemple de rendre à
madère musica tu dit fou de parfums
encensé de ses cheveux de nix brune une
unique c'est quoi une alfa tct orientale
sinon d'une une landing d'accord et noël
tant de l'est les bords noirs des
rocailles ckoi l'hellébore fleur magique
que les prêts s'est employé à un broyage
des trucs dans cette émission tu es sa
maturité nectarines ça veut dire quoi ça
on passe à 7
c'est une invention pas souvent une
invention politique la moindre des
choses
la pêche nectarine la potée de nectar
lourd et de la maturité
le poignet sénestre c'est le poignet
gauche 1
on le dit pas trop quand même non sa
patience l'intérieur l'a effectivement
alors tout ça sur 600 pages
en général ça faisait six cents pages
bah si ce n'est plus ouais voilà encore
alors il ya des critiques qui trouvent
que c'est lisible tu le sais ça de base
on y lit vous avez les critiques qui
visent déjà c'est beau alors si on leur
fournissant pas ce n'est pas atteint on
dit que les critiques c'était d'aider
jeter de malvézy aubenas sur la plupart
quand même sont des gens qui devraient
bien accueillir des façons politique
même si c'était eux mêmes pour ce faire
elle voudrait bien pouvoir le faire part
à l'imaginaire h et riche avoir le cran
d'une expérience assez dur on vous
rappelle et retranscrire et surtout
n'avoir pas le choix de faire autre
chose par sandy imposé j'ai jamais eu de
prix et tu as dit pour les prix j'étais
toujours un peu plus leader
oui j'en saurai plus tard en septembre
je sais pas moi c'est mon héritage
avant-vente câline marque
vous avez beaucoup d'efforts et très
gentiment avait un mal d'esprits que ça
a été génial mais bon beaucoup d'efforts
pour les tricks était quand même
sony vient d'assister pas alors illuminé
comme ça où je devais aller je vais une
chemise à lavallière se passe des choses
pas trop mais je croyais à rien du tout
je sais que ce que je dis entre 2 2
points des blues moi j'ai très bien ces
gens sont des matchs aux vraiment je
peux rien entre eux mais c'est michel
maure piège dans les stations là j'étais
tout petit a juste pas grandement non
sous la table
alors l'avenir at publié un livre qui
fait 167 pages qui s'appelle primavera
toscane un seuil à quai la phrase la
plus longue ça va là les phrases ont
l'air plus tôt que d'habitude non oui
mais les 300 étaient différentes
on écrit comme étant de quatre jours a
tellement de sport alors on lit forcée
d'écrire proliférant avec super ans
quand le thème s'y prête c'est normal la
toscane est austère et limpide
alors toute petite phrase voilà alors
c'est l'histoire c'est une jeune fille
née dans le patro cetto
béni des muses bien évidemment ça va
aller simplement une petite fille qui
qui est l'esprit même de florence est à
dire qu il veut apprendre sa dette et
l'explosion de volonté de savoir le choc
à ce monument inquiets qu'elle est
compétente que le xvème siècle à
florange particulièrement cette jeune
fille de tempérance et fabrice savoir
tellement grand qu'il va aller plus loin
quelle nuit tu mènes soul et l'orgueil
et se casser de référence et qu'elle
sera séchée centre pour être plus chez
albin michel
qu'est ce qui s'est passé bailly s'est
passé mais jamais complètement cette
acceptation et s'est passé qu'ils ont
finalement compris mais il est aussi
j'ai été obligé pour les photos un peu
les gens sachent de quoi satisfaire à
des web à des contrats on établit de
faire un faux début elles sont souvent à
des livres qui sera seul en groupe les
fours avant pour respecter les contrats
vous à les hisser à la porte
tu connais le portrait chinois
[Musique]
j'étais un défaut par exemple je serai
quoi la tempérance la tempérance ils
étaient une injure
une copie dans un texte un avatar une
infirmité
j'ai failli rester enchaîne alors je ne
veux pas répondre et un grave accident
avec ce pc à 1 6 morceaux sur la
longueur et par l'ouest en main ça va ça
s'est bien terminé
une guerre ok c'était obligé d'être une
guerre celle des 7 parce qu'elle est là
avec un vis ta culture un dictateur
benkajjane un supplice
un celui de la question tu vois tu t'en
sors pas mal sauf
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux